mama said nothing's ever gonna come
between us
mama June Shannon and her boyfriend Gino
dope were arrested in Alabama for
possession of a controlled substance I
don't know who she is anymore
June is not in a safe place Gino has got
such a hold on her I need to go over
there and just snatch her up it's gonna
be dangerous
I don't care how many rocks I have to
turn over to find Jade I'm not leaving
Alabama until I do
oh my god Gino crashed into the house
drunk he's a piece of are you stupid
like I just don't think that mama
understands everything she does affect
all of us shoes ah seriously what they
all over their name is honey booboo
pretend Stewart cut sugar and Jennifer
have a reason to take you from eyes
pumpkin I think it's time for us to
rethink this custody agreement I'll see
you in court
what's happening I wanna understand if
your mother loved you buddy's giving up
on her thank you
maaaan said there's people after us they
may come out to you this is go dangerous
situation all that has gone far enough
this could get crazy
I'm about to throw down
nobody knows and what the real story is
don't miss the new season of Mama Chu
family crisis Friday March 27th at 9:00
on WE tv
[Music]